ja ich begrüße alle teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer zu dieser vorlesung meine
erste vorlesung die ich halten darf als
frischgebackener privatdozent zum thema
philosophie der digitalität
ich freue mich dass die vorlesungen
online stattfinden darf weil sie dann
auch sehr gut zum thema der digitalität
passt also wir reden nicht nur
philosophisch über digitalität sondern
wir reden philosophisch im medium in der
sphäre der digitalität über digitalität
und das finde ich sehr angemessen in der
ersten vorlesung der heutigen sitzung
geht es primär darum digitalisierung von
digitalität abzugrenzen also überhaupt
mal den begriff zu definieren
der hier im zentrum steht und zu
definieren oder zu bestimmen was eine
philosophie der digitalität überhaupt
sein könnte ich sag schon soviel vorweg
es gibt eine solche philosophie noch
nicht und wir versuchen hier gemeinsam
dieser vorlesung eine solche philosophie
man ihren grundzügen zu entwickeln und
zu überblicken das soll also im zentrum
stehen und dann wird auch noch ein
ausblick auf die auf einzelnen sitzungen
der vorlesung gegeben ich gebe ihnen
kurzen klaren also erstmal werde ich was
zum didaktischen konzept der vorlesung
sagen das könnte sie interessieren dann
sage ich was zur methode der vorlesung
ich habe mir dabei was überlegt wie wir
uns den begriff der digitalität
philosophisch ernähren und wie wir es
vielleicht auch nicht tun sollten dann
wie ich schon sagte geht es um die
differenz von digitalisierung und
digitalität eine ganz zentrale differenz
die in den meisten fällen auch
wissenschaftlich nicht berücksichtigt
wird weswegen wir auch noch keine
wirkliche philosophie der digitalität
haben weil sie nicht streng genug von
der digitalisierung unterschieden wird
dann komme ich auf den begriff der neue
medien zu sprechen der ganz eng mit dem
begriff der digitalität und auch der
digitalisierung verbunden ist wir müssen
klären wenn wir uns die digitalität zu
denken was überhaupt die neuen medien
sind und wie sie sich zu den alten
medien vor allem jetzt trifft es gibt
aber auch viele andere medien verhalten
das ist ganz nicht die dann gebe ich
eine übersicht über die themen die wir
diese vorlesung im laufe des
wintersemesters behandeln wollen und am
schluss haben wir eine halbe stunde zeit
zu fragen diskussion gerne auch zu
formalen punkten die wir dann nicht
aufgezeichnet
jetzt kann man mal zum taktischen
konzept die vorlesung wie sieht gerade
sehen wird immer freitags von 16 bis 18
uhr kommt empore direkt über so
übertragen
60 minuten lang wird das jeweilige thema
von repräsentiert wie auch jetzt und
versucht argumentativ zu erschließen
circa 16 minuten ein bisschen mehr ein
bisschen weniger
danach gibt es für ca 30 minuten die
gelegenheit zu fragen und zur diskussion
gegebenenfalls auch falls die diskussion
sehr intensiv ausfallen sollte oder
vielleicht auch sehr schleppend
verlaufen sollte in kleingruppen aber
das stelle ich auch zu diskussionen die
60 minütige präsentation dieser gibt es
gerade gehalten wird die wird
aufgezeichnet und im anschluss auf
youtube und auch per push notification
veröffentlicht
jetzt habe ich schon gesagt es gibt eine
app teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer die
schon andere lehrveranstaltungen von mir
kennen wissen was damit gemeint ist ich
meinen die kilo kaarst die gibt es für
android und apple smartphones die wurden
auch schon häufig heruntergeladen
1500 mal also wenn sie sich diese app
herunterladen können sie auf alle
inhalte dieser vorlesung mobil zugreifen
das möchte ich nur sagen und dann hatte
ich es auch schon erwähnt die
aufzeichnungen der ersten 60 minuten
alle vorlesungen werden auf meine
youtube-kanal philo cast mit derweil
circa 4000 100 abonnenten abonnenten
gestellt bei den finden sie auch wenn
sie einfach auf youtube die lowcost
eingeben und das hier ist das logo
so jetzt geht es weiter zur methode der
vorlesung die frage die wir uns sind die
ich mir jetzt auch stellen möchten nicht
nur der heutigen sitzung seien über die
ganze vorlesung das ganze semester
hinweg ist folgende warum sollten wir
uns philosophisch überhaupt mit der
digitalisierung befassen ist dies nicht
eine aufgabe der informatiker anders
gesagt
übertreten wir philosophin und
philosophen nicht unsere unsere domäne
unsere grenzen wenn wir uns mit
digitalisierung befasst wie können wir
uns wie sollten wir uns genuin
philosophisch vielleicht auch kultur
philosophisch mit der digitalisierung
befassen so dass eine informatikerin und
ein informatiker sagt das ist
interessant das wusste ich noch nicht
darüber habe ich mir noch gar keine
gedanken die antwort die ich jetzt hier
vorschlagen möchte lautet die
digitalisierung ist schon längst nicht
mehr nur von interesse für die
informatik sind sie betrifft uns alle
und nicht nur uns alle sondern auch
eigentlich zu jeder tages und nachtzeit
kurz gesagt die digitalisierung ist
nicht mehr nur ein technisches phänomen
ein randphänomen expertin experten der
informatik sondern ein lebenswichtiges
phänomen geworden was unsere realität
immer mehr stimmt ja was sogar zu einer
eigenen realität wird das wird jetzt
gleich zum begriff der digitalität der
häufig so erklärt wird dass eine fusion
von digital digitalisierung und realität
ist das fusionierte geht digitalität
also damit können wir sagen der begriff
der digitalität bezeichnet vorab jetzt
schon mal gesagt so was wie die
lebensweltliche dimension der
digitalisierung
jetzt hat ein junger autor der ein buch
geschrieben hat was ich sehr empfehlen
kann über die 50 wichtigsten dinge der
digitalisierung der specht im jahr 2018
folgendes gesagt geschrieben was ich
hier zu treffen findet sagt der
fortschritt der digitalisierung wird uns
zeitnah mit der wohl größten
zivilisatorischen heraus euro
konfrontieren die sie zu bewältigen
wenn das der fall ist und ich glaube
dass es der fall sein wird ganz absehen
kann man sich aber alle bisherigen
entwicklungen deuten darauf hin dann
sind wir als philosophie und philosophen
sehr gefragt uns darüber begriffliche
gedanken zu machen die nicht nur die
ethik betreffen dieses zitat suggeriert
jetzt dass es hier vor allem ethische
fragen gehe und sozialphilosophen
schicksal auch apps der logische also
erkenntnistheoretische fragestellung die
mit künstlicher intelligenz zu tun haben
das ist ja auch alles eine konsequenz
dieses prozess der digitalisierung oder
auch und urologie es um die frage nach
der bedeutung virtueller realität geht
oder aber auch ästhetik wenn wir uns
fragen ob nicht auch computerspiele
einen wert haben der über die bloße
unterhaltung hinausgeht also ich glaube
hier ist ein wichtiger punkt
angesprochen wir müssen uns hier
dringend gedanken machen mehr denn die
und das ist die motivation dieser
vorlesung das phänomen der
digitalisierung soll als philosophisch
theologische ontologische ethischer und
ästhetischer perspektive betrachtet und
begrifflich durch stromanbietern hier
gibt es noch viele unklarheiten
hier sind wir philosophen und wieder so
offen gefragt ordnung in dieses neue
feld zu bringen
die vorlesung nimmt jetzt eine kritische
zwischenposition 1 bei der
philosophischen analyse der
digitalisierung und sie grenzt sich als
solche von drei komponenten und durchaus
umstrittenen positionen bezüglich der
digitalisierung ab die jetzt im
folgenden kurz präsentieren möchte
zunächst der ideologisierung die
ideologisierung der digitalisierung
meint dass hier
die sie als ein technologisches heils
mittel gefastet häufig finden wir solche
ideologisierung der digitalisierung auch
in form von zukunfts spekulationen etwa
ray kurzweil den sie vielleicht kennen
ich zeigen doch noch sein buch der von
einer nahenden singularität spricht oder
einer silicon valley ideologie wie sich
meine augen treffen julian nida-rümelin
geschrieben hat aber auch in form von
trans und posthum an ismen die eben
glauben dass durch die digitale technik
der mensch wesentlich verbessert und
sogar höher entwickelt werden kann davon
möchte ich mich in dieser vorlesung
abgrenzen auch wenn ich mich darauf
beziehen wird dann möchte ich mich
abgrenzen von der banalisierung
die die auffassung vertrieb das
digitalisierung ein bloß technologisches
medium ist und ein bloßes hilfsmittel
zur alltagsbewältigung aber nicht weiter
würde ist philosophisch betrachtet
werden ich glaube das ist zustand dass
es ihr ein zu reduktionistischen zugang
zu dieser neuen realität die wir durch
die digitale technik vorfinden und
schließlich möchte ich mich im rahmen
der vorlesung abgrenzen von der position
der traumatisierung die ist so eine art
von gegenposition zur ersten position
der ideologisierung die traumatisierung
hält die digitalisierung als eine gefahr
für die jugend vor allem aber auch für
die gesellschaft insgesamt
manfred spitzer den sie vielleicht kennt
spricht von einer digitalen demenz die
dadurch verursacht werde und von einem
digitalen unbehagen was ihm und auch
andere geschlecht auch davon möchte mich
abgrenzen und glaube dass auch so eine
position nicht angemessen ist um die
lebensweltliche bedeutung der
digitalisierung zu fassen und schon gar
nicht philosophisch zu begreifen ich
möchte diese drei positionen von denen
ich nicht ab kennt sind kurz ein
bisschen näher beschreiben erstmals
ideologisierung ich habe schon genannt
ray kurzweil ist hier im zentrum ein
genialer
ingenieur ohne frage der aber immer eben
auch philosophische aussagen getätigt
hat und ich möchten jetzt mal ein
zentrale zitat vorlegen gefragt ist es
singularity the future security
case of technological change
provisoriums impact so die firmen läuft
nur die reverse split vans ford auf der
europeana die scorpions will transform
dem konzept der trierer to give me your
life style mit business wire stewardess
zeitlauf jemand live including der
spitze understanding der single activate
perspektiven des transporters in der
education for future juli understand the
year and changes points view of life mit
general wollen songtitel der liga
zumindest ernst ist clariant us
reflektiert on its implications for his
oder
online kriterien ein sigulla ricaner das
ist jemand der verstanden hat dass bald
durch die technologische innovation eine
besondere situation einen seo la reid
eintreten wird die unser gesamtes welt
verhältnis welt auf unsere welt
auffassung auf den kopf stellen und
transformieren wird noch ein zitat des
security
repräsentation auf dem murger auf einen
kaffee christin schmidt technology
centre in alert der das tier human
parteigrenzen sybase iq routes der
kino.de station post singularity
getrennt jungen erschien und biophysik
an in virtual reality also das findet
ihr eine vermischung nach kurzweil stadt
die unsere biologische natur und unsere
technologische natur betrifft und die
uns im endeffekt besser machen lässt das
ist aus seinem buch the securities nie
die zeit mal kurz den titel des buches
gerade an das buch geschrieben die age
of spirit & machines
and humans trend bayern entschied dass
eine in meinen augen klar post
humanistische perspektive auf die neuen
medien auf die technik hier sehen wir
jetzt von ihm ein bild was eine
exponentielle ein exponentielles
wachstum zeigt auf der x-achse sehen wir
die das jahr als eine prognose das hat
klar den charakter einer zukunft
spekulation bis ins jahr 2100 und auf
der y-achse die
kapazitäten der welchen arbeit also
letztendlich computerleistung jetzt
zeigt er hier in diesem diagramm dass
wir wenn wir so weiter machen mit
unserer technologischen entwicklung der
zukunft sogar die der enc kapazität die
rechenkapazität aller menschliche gehirn
hinaus zu besteigen und da sich hierbei
um exponentielles wachstum hat streckt
ist immer schneller mit der zeit und so
könnte eben vielleicht im jahr 2100 das
muss man schauen wir so eine
singularität eintreten wo diese kurve so
steigert dass diese exponentielle
fortschritt an technologien an
denkleistung etwas ganz neuem führen
wird dass auf der technologischen
innovation super intelligenzen reagieren
die uns vielleicht zu hören da treffen
oder durch die wir eben auf ein neues
level katapultiert werden wenn wir sie
implementieren in unsere biologische
natur davon möchte ich mich abgrenzen
ich halte das zwar eine interessante
spekulation aber niemand auf eine
spekulation ich glaube die philosophin
und wir philosophen sollten wenn wir
philosophie betreiben nicht spekulieren
sondern wir sollten suchen begrifflich
zu argumentieren und das was ist
durchaus etwas extrapolieren aber immer
schön auf der ebene der begriffe bleiben
und hier klärung verklärung säure und
nicht für interessante antizipation die
ihr fiktionalen charakter davon durch
die nicht abgrenzen so jetzt gibt es die
banalisierung die besagt digitalisierung
als hilfreiches instrument und medium
ist insofern interessant um unseren
alltag besser zu bewältigen
digitalisierung als technologisches
verlieren
zudem hat die philosophie nicht mehr zu
sagen als zur elektrifizierung es gibt
keine philosophie der elektrifizierung
mir zu uns keine bekannt vielleicht gab
es mal eine so um 1900 oder seit wann
ist die ratifizierung gibt man jetzt
sagen bei der pariser weltausstellung 18
170 herum vielleicht gab es eine
philosophie der elektrifizierung aber
sie gibt es nicht mehr und genauso
könnte man jetzt sagen aus der
perspektive der banalisierung dann
brauchen wir auch keine kilo sowie die
digitalisierung oder der gerade die
tante es ist dabei handelt sich dabei
nur um ein technisches technologisches
phänomen das überlassen wir den
technikerinnen und techniker
es keine philosophie gibt warum sollte
ist dann gerade eine philosophie der
digitalisierung geben das ist auch eine
frage die wir platzieren stellen wollen
und diese banalisierung strategie die
auch immer stark rettung zu mystischen
charakter hat die wird auch so
argumentieren gut wenn wir uns schon mit
der digitalisierung philosophie
beschäftigen sollten dann doch
bitteschön als thema der technik
philosophie aber bitte nicht dass sich
der un ok oder der ästhetik das gehört
alles bereiche technik und auch
hiergegen möchte ich argumentiere ich
glaube die digitalisierung hat ein
solches ausmaß angenommen dass die
technik philosophie nicht mehr
hinreichend ist um sie methodisch zu
begreifen wir müssen hier den fokus auf
halten und eine ganze vielzahl an
philosophische perspektiven die nicht
nur technologisch unvermietet auf dieses
phänomen werfen das soll auch am rand
dieser vorlesung geschehen ja jetzt gibt
es auch die dramaturgie sierung
traumatisierung die virtuelle realität
die mit dieser digitalen video einher
geht die wird im rahmen der
traumatisierung psychologisch
neurologisch oder sucht theoretisch
interpretiert er ist manfred spitzer ein
besonders exponierte denker der sagt
während der konsum von alkohol nikotin
sowie weichen und harten illegalen
rauschten rückläufig ist steigen
computer und internetsucht dramatisch an
die regierung ist ratlos also das ist
auch ein zugang der sagt diese ganze
technische entwicklung virtuelle
realität auch immersion also dass
einbezogen werden diese virtuellen
welten das ist vor allem gefährlich das
ist aus psychiatrische psychologischer
sicht höchst problematisch weil es sucht
evoziert und uns letztendlich krank
macht noch ein zitat die moderne
gehirnforschung blick mal dass wir bei
der nutzung der digitalen medien in
einem größeren rahmen allen kurze sorge
haben in unser gehirn befindet sich in
einem fortwährenden veränderungsprozess
und daraus folgt zwingend dass der
tägliche umgang mit digitalen medien
eines nicht haben kann keine auswirkung
auf uns die nutzer ich würde spitze hier
zustimmen dass unsere tägliche umgang
mit digitalen medien sehr wohl starke
auswirkungen auf uns hat dass diese
auswirkungen aber zunächst mal moralisch
oder wie auch immer in differenzen dh
diese auswirkungen sind durchaus positiv
aber auch negativ
sie sind aber und darauf kommt sie
werden von neuer art die so nicht
direkte vorgänger habe das heißt wir
haben sie mit einer neuen realität zu
tun und die müssen wir erstmal ganz
begrifflich korrekt beschreiben bevor
wir solche die gefahren monieren und
auch alarmistisch werden die spitze ins
tue ich glaube das wird dieser neuen
entwicklung nicht gerecht und mein
letztes zitat von ihm eine ganze reihe
von studien zum medienkonsum zeigt
mittlerweile über deutlich dass diese im
höchsten maße anlass zur besorgnis geben
sollte darum habe ich dieses buch die
digitale demenz heißt es geschrieben es
wird in den augen vieler menschen ein
unbequemes buch seien ein sehr unbequem
ist als psychiater und gehirnforschung
kann ich aber nicht anders also ich
glaube dass wir die entwicklung der
digitalisierung mich den hirn
vorschreiben dass man schnell verlassen
sollten zu reflektieren so dass mich
hier als philosophin und philosophen
durchaus einen sehr guten eigenen
zugriff haben die zeige ich ihnen noch
ein paar bücher von herrn spitze einmal
die besagte digitale demenz wie wir uns
und unsere kinder um den verstand
bringen daraus sind diese zitate sieht
man monitore hier sieht man
spielekonsolen auffällig ist dass häufig
die debatte um die digitalisierung sich
nur auf internetnutzung und
computerspiele konzentriert das ist in
meinen augen eine verengung ein
reduktionismus der auch wieder in die
banalisierung führt als wir sehen die
dramatisierung und die banalisierung und
die ideologisierung miteinander zusammen
darin auch dass sie dem phänomen wie ich
glaube nicht gerecht werden dennoch ein
buch selber krank wie das digitalisierte
leben unsere gesundheit ruiniert und
plus die smartphone epidemie gefahren
für gesundheit bildung und gesellschaft
korrektes ist dass diese neuen
entwicklungen auch problematische
tendenz mit spüren so falsch ist es in
meinen augen sie nur alarmistisch zu
beklagen uns warnen hier wird die
positiven entwicklungen die damit
einhergehen völlig unterschätzt hier
verstehen wir uns ein blick auf neue
realität die wir gerade erst
phänomenologische erkunden und
begrifflich kartieren müssen ja so jetzt
habe ich eine abgrenzung vorgenommen
meteorologische art von positionen die
ich glaube nicht dass sie nicht gerecht
werden diese philosophie der
digitalisierung oder sowie der
digitalität jetzt komme ich aber auch
den bfd digitalität zu sprechen ich
hatte schon gesagt die digitalität
begriff der digitalität muss von der
begriff der digitalisierung
unterschieden wird
digitalisierung bedeutet kurz gesagt die
technische technologische überführung
von analogen in digitale daten und
strukturen alles von einem kontinuum des
analogen in ein gewandeltes durch 0 und
1 ein diskretes schema das ist die der
prozess der digitalisierung der ist
sicherlich hoch interessante ausbildung
so verschoss ich glaube aber dass wir da
noch eine andere perspektive können
nämlich auf die lebensweltliche realität
der digitalisierung jenseits haltlose
technik und instrument an tät damit
meine ich unseren alltag der immer mehr
durch digitale strukturen geprägt wird
so dass die technische seite gar nicht
mehr im zentrum steht sondern eben eine
neue lebensform für den neuen realitäten
energien vor allem durch das internet
aber auch durch andere medien das
phänomen der digitalität verhält sich
reflexiv zum phänomen der
digitalisierung was bedeutet dass die
digitalisierung ist domäne der
informatik und informationswissenschaft
die digitalität ist domäne der kultur
und geisteswissenschaft und deswegen
auch der philosophie es geht hier nicht
nur um die technik also welche da haben
wir auch als philosophin und philosophen
viel zu geben geladen sind es geht darum
wie diese technik unsere lebenswelt
verändert und was damit für neue
realitäten einhergeht ich glaube es gibt
jede menge neue realitäten die wir immer
mehr auch kennenlernen auf die werde ich
natürlich im rahmen der vorlesung auch
eigens zu sprechen kommen das scheint
mir ein ganz wichtiger gescheitert das
seien deswegen nenne ich jetzt auch die
vorlesung eine philosophie der
digitalität und nicht eine philosophie
die digitalisierung das sollen dann ihre
technik philosophie und technik
philosophen informatikerin informatiker
mit philosophischen interesse ton
ja das thema digitalität ist der begriff
ist ein neuer begriff der gibt es noch
gar nicht so lange man kann sich auf den
wikipedia-artikel mal informieren er hat
und jüngster zeit insbesondere aus
kulturwissenschaftlicher perspektive
interesse erfahren zu nennen ist hier
das buch kultur der digitalität von
felix stalder und ihr schreiben diesem
buch seit dem jahr 2000 verbinden sich
viele der bis teilen von einer
unabhängigen entwicklungen verstärken
und verändern sich und bilden nun eine
neue kulturelle konstellation vor allem
das internet ist hier als entwicklung zu
nennen er spricht von einer kohärenten
kultur der digitalität im singular man
damit es gibt nicht verschiedene
kulturen der digital sondern
verschiedene strömungen die
digitalisierung einhergehen kulturelle
die vereinen sich zu einer ziemlich
kohärenten einzelnen auch einzigartige
kultur der digitalität jetzt kann man
sich fragen wie es diese kultur zu
verstehen er spricht von einer enormen
vervielfältigung der kulturellen
möglichkeiten durch die digitalisierung
und den drei formen dieser kultur der
digitalität referenziert
gemeinschaftlichkeit und algorithmen sie
tätig kommen kurz darauf zu sprechen
referent steht dort dass wir immer mehr
medien zur verfügung haben auf die bezug
nehmen können wir können zum beispiel
die die teilen sehr schnell im internet
damit hängt auch die
gemeinschaftlichkeit zusammen alles und
viel mehr zueinander diese physischen
grenzen die wir durch das analoge
gewollt sich die verschwimmen immer mehr
und die algorithmen zieht bedeutet dass
diese vielzahl an datenmaterial an
informationen durch algorithmen durch
künstliche intelligenz handhabbar
gemacht werden so dass es gar nicht mehr
so sehr auf uns ankommen das ebenso drei
faktoren finde ich sehr zentral ich
glaube man kann auch viele andere
komponenten und ich glaube auch man kann
entgegennimmt oder so schick auf die
digitalität dürfen ja bislang existiert
noch keine philosophie der digitalität
das heißt unsere vorlesung hat
pioniercharakter es existieren jedoch
drei verschiedene zugänge zum thema der
digitalität nämlich erstens ein medien-
oder symbole und zeichen theoretische
zugang zum phänomen der digitalität was
philosophischen perspektiven hier ist
sybille krämer zu nennen die eine der
pionierinnen auf diesen gebieten ist die
im jahr 2000 herum mit dem aufkommen des
internets einige publikationen dazu
veröffentlicht hat dann gibt es eine app
ist theologischen zugang der den begriff
der information und denke infos fähre
ins zentrum stellt hier ist luciano von
video zu nennen auf den baum noch kurz
eingehen werde und zum schluss ein
phänomenologischen theologische zugang
der digitalität von begriff der
virtuellen realität verschließt hier ist
war tobias flitsch kann sondern mit
einem neuen buch aber auch ich habe dazu
bisschen kompliziert und jetzt stelle
ich die mal ganz kurz vor erstmals
krämer ihre kulturen symbol
theoretischen zugangs 1998 ein buch
geschrieben veröffentlicht als damit man
medien computer realität untertitel
wirklichkeit vorstellung und neue medien
die beiträge dieses bandes zentrieren
sich um treiben andere verwandte themen
erstens in einer grundlagen
theoretischen perspektive wird die frage
gestellt was ist ein medium dann wird
der computer als ein medium thematisiert
schließlich geht es um veränderungen
unsere wirklichkeit verständnisses im
gefolge von phänomen die mit dem einsatz
digitalisierten medien verbunden sind
das war wie gesagt für genau 20 jahren
mittlerweile würde ich sagen würden wir
nicht mehr schreiben dass es um die
veränderung und zur wirklichkeit
verständnis geht das mit dem neuen
medien einhergeht sondern das um die
veränderung in unsere wirklichkeit
selbst geht also nicht unser verständnis
der wirklichkeit ändert sich oder das
auch so unsere wirklichkeit durch die
miete also neun medien werden immer mehr
und logisch signifikant und das ist eine
perspektive die die in diesem band er
beiseite gelassen wird jetzt erklärt
sich dadurch dass sie in dieser zeit um
2000 die neuen medien noch nicht so
entwickelt waren sind dass ihre
ökologische signifikanz noch nicht so
klar zu tage treten konnte jetzt gab in
der zwischenzeit zum 2010 herum eine
zehn jahre später von dem oxforder
philosophen luciano verbieten eine
flasche 4 auf information und ein buch
mit dem titel die info sphäre die vierte
revolution wie die infos werden unser
leben verändert steine flogen die
folgendes in diesem buch skizziere ich
lediglich ein paar ideen für eine
philosophie der information in form
einer philosophie der über geschichte
seine philosophie der natur in form
einer philosophie die infos für für eine
philosophische anthropologie form einer
vierten revolutionen unserem
selbstverständnis nach der
kopernikanischen der darwinschen und der
freuden und für eine philosophie der
politik in form der entwicklung von
multi akteurs systemen die sich die
aufgabe globale probleme zu bewältigen
gewachsen zahlen können hier steht jetzt
veränderte griff der
informationszentrum die infos fähre ist
nach lohr ii die vor allem die sphäre
des internets die es uns ermöglicht
jederzeit an jedem ort zu gewünschten
informationen zu kommen die infos fähre
ist aber verbunden mit der bisherigen
sphäre der gedruckten büchern der
schrift das wird nach florida
zusammengeführt ja und dann gibt es eben
diesen dritten zugang demir
phänomenologische theologischen zugang
der sich an begriffe virtuellen realität
orientiert hier wie bereits gesagt ob
wir nicht ein interessantes buch cyber
places philosophisch annäherung an den
virtuellen ort er sagt freund ist
während sich die orte der alltagswelt
angesichts der neuen medien eine
relativierung möglicherweise sogar einer
neubestimmung hinsichtlich ihrer
lebenswege bedeutet ausgesetzt sehen
dreht in der virtuellen welt eine neue
art von orten zutage deren einordnung
zwischen die illusion fiktion und
wirklichkeit noch nicht eindeutig
geklärt ist konkret geht es hier um
computerspiele koliska demonstriert
diesen virtuellen ort anhand des
computerspiels minecraft war ein zitat
virtualität und wirklichkeit sind ihm
ein spannungsverhältnis gegenseitiger
bezüglich kite geraten das ist zu
bestimmen hier würde ich wohl nicht
völlig zu stimmen wir müssen klären was
überhaupt virtuelle realität ist und
darüber soll es auch in dieser vorlesung
vorangehen zum schluss noch mein zugang
habe ich ein buch veröffentlicht mit dem
titel was ist digitalität
philosophische und pädagogische
perspektiven und im vorwort haben mir
geschrieben mit meiner mitherausgeberin
während die digitalisierung das
technische phänomene der umwandlung
analoge digitale information betrifft
reflektiert die digitalität oder die
filmmusik wieder die vitalität von einem
meter neben mir auf diese transformation
sie betrifft diese transformation hin
sich ihren kulturellen ästhetischen
unter logischen und ethischen bedeutung
so viele jetzt zum rückblick und ein
kleiner ausblick noch mittlerweile gibt
es sogar eine arge arbeitsgemeinschaft
der deutschen gesellschaft wie zum thema
philosophie der digitalität auch ein
motto und eine adresse digitale für
einen punkt leben des mutter ist
folgendes computer und
digitaltechnologie das internet und
virtuelle realität latifi zieren und
digitale forschungsmethoden maschinelles
lernen und künstliche intelligenz
all diese themen sind nicht nur tief in
unseren alltag und unsere lebenswelt
eingedrungen sondern bestimmen kultur
und wissenschaften bildung
technologie sowie die infrastrukturen
der verwaltung der digitale wandel mit
wird mit der bedeutung des buchdrucks
oder der industrialisierung verglichen
wir befinden uns in einem übergang von
der kultur technik der script wahlen den
rand seiner digitalen realität
jugendwerks lesbarkeit der welt
transformiert sich in vielen bereichen
ist eine maschinenlesbare
universums brauchen wir vielleicht eine
neuartige eine digitale aufklärung auch
diese frage werden wir im lauf der
vorlesung uns stellen
sei es eine windows wieder digitalität
muss die psychologischen und
theologischen ethischen und ästhetischen
dimensionen derjenigen realität
analysieren die auf den neuen medien wie
zum beispiel das internet reagieren als
leitbegriff erweist sich dabei der
bekiffte virtuellen realität die ich in
meiner vorlesung jetzt gleichermaßen
verloser simulation von illusion und
fiktion verstand entscheiden möchte der
dennoch darauf bezogen bleibt weil er
wie ich argumentiere elegante oder
momente dieser anderen realität
simulations- formen beinhaltet dieses
verhältnis müssen wir in amt dieser
vorlesung genau erklären
digitalität erweist sich damit als eine
realität einer hass wenn wir sie als
virtuelle realität verstehen die sich
zum gegenstand verschiedenster
philosophie schon zugriffe machen lässt
digitalität konstituiert anders gesagt
ein neues philosophisches forschungsfeld
forschung ist paradigma wie es nun
allerdings schon die gender philosophie
und schon seit einiger zeit länger die
neuro philosophie oder die straff
philosophie ist davon bin ich zumindest
überzeugt
jetzt möchte ich auch noch auf dem wege
des mediums an geben zumindest des neuen
mediums es gibt einen kanadischen
kulturwissenschaftler der erstmal
schnittblumen und gerhard an gut
geschrieben mit dem titel der guttenberg
galaxie die gutenberg galaxis und er
schreibt 3,4 cent oder technology
patissier cf annähert für resources
tape.tv region entlein ist rapper ist
shapes nord an die private cents
welches
tatorte patterns auf kommunal
interdependenz und noch ein zitat in
diesem medium der shakes & controls
scale in form auf jungen association und
action content or use of china ist es
den effekt shaping the form of human
association berglund geht sobald er sagt
das medium ist gar nicht so sehr als
instrument zu verstehen als
vermittlungsinstanz wie es ja des
lateinischen medium heiligtum das medium
selbst wird performativ als eigene
realität sichtbar sagt deswegen ein
medium is the message also das medium
ist die botschaft es ist nicht die
überbringerin der botschaft zumindest
selbst bedeutsam strukturiert ich würde
noch einen schritt weiter gehen das
medium selbst hat auch unter logische
funktion es selbst verändert unsere
wirklichkeit wie wir zum beispiel in
handels internet sehen was die ich
glaube gar nicht zutreffend als medium
beschrieben werden kann da auch in der
neue begriffe ich würde vorschlägen
schlagen als ein handlungsraum das
scheint mir am nächsten
ja wenn es um den neuen medien geht hat
auch nur tschernobyl jetzt seien bereits
vorgestellt buch die vierte revolution
über die infos hier folgendes gesagt die
neuen medien sind zitat umwelt gestalten
anthropologischen soziale und
interpretativen kräftig sie schaffen und
prägen unsere geistige und materielle
wirklichkeit verändern unser verständnis
modifizieren die wir miteinander in
beziehung treten und uns auf uns selbst
beziehen und sie bringen unsere welt
deuten auf einen neuen besseren stand
und all das tun sie ebenso tief greifen
wie umfassend und unablässig also
florida geht jetzt so weit die neuen
medien durchaus als wirklichkeit
verändern tanz sybille krämer hat im
jahr 2000 noch von der veränderten
wirklichkeit wahrnehmung gesprochen
rädigke csu in wirklichkeit aus und er
sagt es ist eine verbesserung also hat
herrn sehr optimistischen zugriff man
muss natürlich immer auch die
schattenseiten der digitalisiert
betrachten die einer ethischen reflexion
bedürfen auch hier vor allem steht das
internet im zentrum
nachdem ich jetzt hier ab april
mineralische dinge gesagt habe zur
anlage der vorlesung möchte ich jetzt
auf den genauen vorlesungsplan eingehen
und einen kurzen ausblick geben in den
nächsten vorlesung der zeit lang fünften
nur wenn man werden wir uns mit der
kultur der digitalität befassen hier
verhandeln wir felix stall das buch
kommt zu der digitalität wollen aber
noch einen stärker medien
philosophischen blick darauf werfen und
vor allem nach der bedeutung der neuen
medien fragen auch als blumenberg wird
hier im zentrum stehen und er ist
kassierer mit seinen symbolischen formen
die sich auch darauf beziehen lassen
aber in meinen augen dieses phänomen der
digitalität nicht vollständig begreifen
können kultur der digitalität wird
unsere ernährung zur eigentlichen
philosophie der digitalen in der darauf
folgenden vorlesungen werden wir uns mit
der ebs theologie der erkenntnistheorie
der digitalität befassen und hier wird
zur ersten künstliche intelligenz und
inter objektivität zentrum stehen ich
habe den begriff jetzt mal hier
eingeführt inter objektivität bedeutet
in meinen augen dass wir immer mehr zu
den dingen zu den künstlichen
intelligenzen zu den maschinen zu den
smartphones ein verhältnis her stimmt
was uns durchgängig
objekt unterscheidung aufhebt wir
betrachten uns nicht mehr so sehr als
subjekte und die dinge mit denen wir
operieren dann künstliche intelligenz
smartphones als objekte sondern sind
teil unserer lebenswelt und deswegen
finde ich sollte inter subjektivität
erweitern ergänzen um den begriff der
inter objektivität der mir die
lebensweltliche realität von künstliche
intelligenz von smart objects
sehr treffend zu beschreiben scheint
dass du der erste teil der piste monopol
der digitalität sein in der darauf
folgenden vorlesung am 19 november
werden wir uns dann mit dem internet
befassen und hier habe ich den begriff
der anzug identität
ins spiel gebracht ich glaube im
internet wird eben auch die grenze des
subjekts
überschritten indem wir unsere meinungen
gedanken sonst die mentalen inhalte
teilen und in ein medium das internet
führen so dass es die grenzen der des
bloßen individuums übersteigt das heißt
wir kommen uns immer näher auch mit
blick auf unsere subjektiven gehalte die
durchs internet objektiviert werden die
werden äußert und vernetzt auch die
vernetzung spielt hier eine ganz große
rolle das internet scheint mir sehr
zentral so sein dann in der darauf
folgenden vorlesen und am 26
november kommen wir auf die ontologie
der digitalität zu sprechen hier möglich
ganz zentral die frage aufwerfen was
eigentlich virtuelle realität ist und
wie sie sich den simulationen fiktionen
und sonstigen formen der
medialität unterscheiden wie sie sich
auch darauf bezieht das scheint mir ganz
wichtig zu sagen bei ersten wenn wir
erklären was virtuelle realität ist
können wir auch so meine these eine
ethik der digitalität und die muss
nämlich ein realitäts begriff erst
voraussetzen denen sie dann normativ
bewerten wenn das nicht klar ist ob sie
es bei virtuelle realität um eine bloße
simulation ein großes spiel handelt dann
werden auch unsere ethischen zugriffe
darauf problematisch wenn es nur ein
spiel ist dann hat das gleich einen
anderen ethischen gehalt als eine
wirkliche realität
dann in der darauf folgenden vorlesungen
der ersten im dezember am dritten
dezember kommt da kommen wir auf den
zweiten teil der ontologie der
digitalität zu sprechen nämlich dass wer
sich den ubiquitären präsentismus nennen
damit meine ich dass durch das internet
auch durch die digitalität uns raum und
zeit logik verändert wird wir befinden
uns im virtuellen raum wenn wir mal
bestimmt haben nicht mehr in einer
räumlichen distanz zu anderen objekten
sondern alles rückt viel näher und auch
zeitlich wird alles viel näher wir
können vergangenen inhalte sofort wieder
präsent machen wir könnten jedem ort
jederzeit alle informationen prinzipiell
zu greifen das verändert unser raum und
zeit verständnis und da auch möglich
eingeben ubiquitäre präsentismus man
überall und bieten überall können wir
alles sofort präsent machen ich glaube
das ist ganz wichtig diese zeitliche
bestimmung die auch in den bereich der
ökologie der digitalität feld nachdem
wir diese ontologischen fragen geklärt
haben oder zumindest an gerissen haben
können wir dann auf die ethischen fragen
zu greifen die wir davor in meinen augen
nicht sinnvoll beantworten können im
ersten teil am 10 dezember werden wir
uns mit dem internet befassen dass ich
jetzt vorschlagen möchte einen
virtuellen handlungsraum zu nehmen und
nicht primär ein medium das wäre zu
schwach das internet ist kein neues
medium sondern ist die bedingung von
medialität durch das internet können wir
neue medien wie zum beispiel facebook
und so weiter entwickeln aber das
internet als solches ist er die basis
für solche neuen medien und es ist eben
auch in handlungsraum wie interagieren
im internet angesichts der virtuellen
realität und angesichts der römerzeit
logik auf eine ganz neue weise das
stellt natürlich die frage wie wir uns
im internet verhalten sollen und ob es
zum beispiel ein recht auf einen
digitalen neuantrag gibt ob wir das
recht haben sollen dass unsere spuren im
internet gelöscht werden sollten weil
wir sie ja prinzipiell immer wieder
aufdecken können es gibt diesen schönen
schmuck das internet vergisst nichts das
kann man auch problematisieren aber sie
kennen vielleicht das internet wo sie
zur seiten wiederherstellen könnten die
vor zehn jahren mal existieren
mittlerweile schon lange nicht mehr
alles hat eben diesen starken
dokumentarischen charakter so dass alles
irgendwie präsent ist oder auch irgendwo
vor sich herumgeistert und hier stellen
sich gravierend ethische fragen die wir
als philosophin und philosophen nicht
nur aber eben auch angehen müssen das
internet mit seinen handlungsraum in der
achten vorlesung am 7 17.12.10 gehen wir
noch mal auf die ethik ein und diesmal
fragen uns ob künstliche intelligenz
wirklich handeln kann
allzu schnell wird auch von künstliche
intelligenz zugeschrieben so geredet als
ob sie entscheiden können als ob sie
autonom sein sprich autonomes fahren das
sollten wir problematisieren die firmen
ist künstliche intelligenz wirklich
intelligenz im gehirn kann sie wirklich
etwas tun müssen aufpassen dass mich
hier kein animismus vertreten also zu
tun als ob es sich hierbei um lebewesen
handle oder gar um menschen also deine
antwort profilierung wir müssen wirklich
aufpassen
dennoch glaube ich dass wir gewisse akte
künstliche intelligenz zu schreiben
können mustererkennung ich glaube dass
wir von erkennen sprechen können aber
hier ist noch ganz viel begriffliche
arbeit nötig um eben dann auch am ende
eine ethische bewertung dieser neuen
entwicklung der künstlichen intelligenz
vornehmen zu können die vor allem anhand
der entwicklung künstlicher neuronaler
netze sichtbar wir werden uns also fall
auf künstliche neuronale netze
beschränken und erneuten vorlesung der
ersten im neuen jahr werden wir uns
nochmal mit der ewige digitalität
befassen und versuchen wie schon in der
ersten ersten teil der ethik eine ethik
des virtuellen raumes vor allem eine
ethik des internets zu entwickeln welche
regeln sollten die gelten wie sind
handlungen internet überhaupt konzipiert
und wie sollten sie zu bewerten seien
häufig liegt ja der verdacht nein das
internet sei seine art wilder westen
dass er alles erlaubt wir sehen immer
mehr je mehr das im detail unsere
lebenswirklichkeit wird dass es so
leicht nicht ist aber ich glaube dass
unsere bisherige ethischen oder auch
juristischen kategorie nicht eins zu
eins von der analogen welt auf die
virtuelle realität ist internet
übertragbar ist das heißt dann müssen
uns wirklich überlegen was verändert
sich hier durch die antritt raum und
zeit logik auch bezüglich ethisch oder
zugriffe eine eins zu eins übertragung
greift in meinen augen viel zu kurz
der cd vorlesung werden wir uns dann wie
kommen so langsam zum ende der ethik der
digitalität widmen das heißt der
ästhetik der digitalität widmen das
heißt wir werden sehen dass virtuelle
realität
durchaus auch ästhetischen gehalt haben
hier ist zunächst mal zudem kann
virtuelle kunst es gibt mittlerweile
sich wissen dass alles digitale kunst
die nicht kopierbar ist die nicht
beliebig und bremst eben verfehlt fertig
sein die ein unikat darstellt und dann
sollten wir uns fragen wie verhält sich
die digitale virtuelle kunst zur
herkömmlichen analogen kunst lassen sich
die kategorien eins zu eins übertragen
oder muss durch die anderen raum und
zeit logik auch eine neue form von
ästhetik wenn modifizierte form von
ästhetik entwickelt werden ich glaube
dass letzteres der fall hier ist auch
noch viel arbeit zu tun es gibt bereits
virtuelle museen aber ich glaube wir
sollten uns einfach das virtuelle
kunstkurs hier das setzt natürlich
voraus dass wir zuvor geklärt haben was
überhaupt virtuelle realität ist wer
möchte schon geld bezahlen für bloße
simulation oder illusion haben wir
wollen wenn wir von kunst reden ist auch
mit einer realität zu tun haben die
immer natürlich auch fiktionalen
charakter haben darf kunst hat immer
einzuhalten karate ist aber dennoch ja
ja wir wollen uns dann auch noch mal in
der elften vorlesung mit der ästhetik
der digitalität befassen diesmal anhand
von computerspielen die immer mehr
eingang unser leben zu finden manfred
spitzer sieht das ja sehr problematisch
er würde computerspiele vor allem unter
dem gesichtspunkt einer suchterkrankung
oder das medien über konsums
thematisieren ich glaube dass sich
computerspiele sowohl ethisch als auch
ästhetisch sehr sehr interessant
beschreiben lassen jenseits von
befürchtungen in richtung einer
suchterkrankung ein kompetenter umgang
mit computerspielen dann ist in meinen
augen sehr fruchtbares weiblich auf ganz
neue weise fiktionalität illusion
simulator und realität
verbinden können was mit analogen medien
so nicht geht natürlich müssen wir auch
wenn es um die nutzung gibt eine große
tugend entwickeln stichwort
medienkompetenz das ist auch noch ein
thema was wir im rahmen der ethik der
digitalität thematisieren sollte als
digitale tugenden wie man im internet
angesichts der überfülle informationen
kompetent ihnen umgeht sprich
letztendlich auch eine didaktik oder
pädagogik der digitalität wie wir
heranwachsende kinder und jugendliche
dahin führen müssen so dass sie einen
kompetenten zugriff auf diese neuen
realitäten haben die nicht mehr von
unserer lebenswelt wegzudenken ist ja so
viel dazu dann kommen wir noch in einer
sitzung auf die anthropologie der
digitalität zu sprechen damit meine ich
die frage machte veränderung des
menschen des menschen im digitalen
virtuellen hier ist sicherlich die frage
von interesse inwiefern wir trans mannis
tisch bei uns verändern wie ich schon
vorher sagte glaube ich nicht dass der
transport muss eine adäquate antwort auf
die herausforderung der digitalisierung
sind wir müssen dennoch die frage stellt
wie sich der mensch verändert durch die
digitalen medien im virtuellen raum hier
könnte man auch die frage nach avataren
stellen das führt dann wieder zum thema
computerspiele
das finde ich eine spannende frage auch
so was wie in herrn smend ist hier
angebracht reise die verbesserung des
menschen durch implementierung digitaler
strukturen aber hier möchte ich immer
eine kritische differenz zum trans und
post harmonisch muss festhalten das
scheint mir nicht adäquat zu sein dann
kommen wir noch auf die politik der
digitalität zu sprechen das sind auch
ihr exkursen oder die politische
philosophie der digitalität damit einher
geht wiederum die frage nach der
verfügbarkeit von informationen vor
allem des internets wie ich schon sagte
das internet sein handlungsraum das
heißt es ist ein raum wo wir unsere
freiheit und autonomie verwirklichen so
wie wir auch auf der straße oder soll es
im analogen unsere freiheit
verwirklichen so können wir das auch im
virtuellen raum wenn das der fall ist
wenn das internet ein handlungsraum ist
dann sollten wir alle ein recht auf
diesen handlungsraum haben ähnlich wie
wir ein recht auf frische luft haben
sollten oder haben das heißt wie sollte
das internet politisch gesteuert
kontrolliert hier ist dann auch die
frage nach den großkonzernen google und
so weiter und monopol auf die freie
verfügbarkeit es gibt bereits bayern
wlan in bayern können sie an ganz
verschiedenen orten kostenlos in der
zukunft haben ist lange nicht überall in
deutschland der fall in anderen ländern
hat überall selbst erobern überall
internet also die frage welche bedeutung
wie ich es lebenswichtig recht haben wir
auf ein internet wenn es doch ein
handlungsraum ist und wie sollten wir
damit umgehen wenn gewisse länder der
bild kein oder auch menschen in
bestimmten regionen der welt kein
zugriff auf internetseiten wie fern ist
internet ein menschenrecht das sollte
man auch diskutieren ja in der letzten
vorlesung gibt es dann eine
schlussbetrachtung da wollen wir einen
blick in die zukunft werfen das heißt da
können wir ja erst mal ein bisschen
spekulieren ist hier jährige entwicklung
betrachten und dann extrapolieren also
fragen wie das digitale weiter eingang
in unsere lebensmittel finden wird hier
ist raum für spekulationen gegeben dass
gehört immer mit der digitalisierung zu
technik dass wir ihre utopien entwerfen
hier sollten wir uns aber immer fragen
wie viel diese gedankenexperimente
berechtigt sind philosophisch und wo sie
nicht mehr sinnvoll sind als wir fragen
immer nach dem philosophischen zweck und
der berechtigung von gedanken
experimenten und zukunftsvisionen ja das
war meine kurze vorstellung der
programme die wir im rahmen dieser
vorlesen verfolgen ich bedanke mich für
die aufmerksamkeit und wir gehen jetzt
über zur diskussion